[Music]
you can talk it's all the other does
anybody think it would be possible to
make a live action version of Beauty and
the Beast when the animated classic came
out 25 years ago right no way makes this
such a technological success it's pretty
amazing of course last night was the
star-studded premiere Emma Watson showed
off in this Oscar de la Renta jumpsuit
but the 26 year olds been pretty much
killing it on her global press blitz I
have to go to go through these first
word that comes to mind when you see
some of these leather fake leather
monochrome Kate
[Music]
if my five-year-old self knew I was
gonna get to do this she would have died
died supporting Emma at the premiere -
former Harry Potter co-stars making a
date night Matt Damon and wife Luciana
and these two without their adorable
baby girl
leading the beast would be a good first
movie for Luna yeah I know and she'll be
so proud of daddy in this movie John
puts a new twist on Celine Dion's duet
from the original I was at the beginning
of my career it put me on a map I'm so
nervous for her to hear the final
version yeah but if you want to talk
about real nerves watch the stars tackle
our Disney Princess quiz oh my god how
many Disney Princesses can you say in
ten seconds starting right now
Pocahontas area Mulan Jasmine Jasmine
well oh the frozen girl Elsa Anna
Rapunzel Aurora come on brother on earth
the only one I know is Belle because I
have three boys and otherwise it's
Batman and Superman so bye
[Music]
you